you know North Korea gets a batter out
by the way but have you have you been
there I have beautiful really nice
listen okay
just listen to me all right it's
beautiful I wouldn't that wet okay
these gigantic green mountains okay
crisp blue skies imagine right these
little yellow mounds of dead bodies
beautiful I just want to do that just to
do that you know man
I got a crazy story about North Korea no
oh yeah on state way well horrible quick
on stage that works but here in this
room it [ __ ] dies a bomb on stage it
works here in the room and [ __ ] bomb
it was a North Korean ballistic missile
big it bombed so hard well you don't
have to edit that out that fell I just
ain't it in my own [ __ ] [ __ ] tell me
about North Korea my friends oh this is
the story I had so my mom goes to church
of Virginia Korean church and there's
these missionaries from our church that
went to North Korea did you know spread
the word of Jesus yeah they got caught
right got imprisoned they said good any
guy yet they got caught their base is
like if you don't pay this fine in three
days we're gonna put all you guys to
death but the guy wrote a letter to the
church don't worry about me if it's my
fate you guys will have to pay the money
do you know how much do you know much it
was just take a guess how much it was
and I got grin you're the only one that
most people gets like 200,000 it was
3,500 bucks tell you why I know it's cuz
in the Philippines you could get away
with [ __ ] murder for a hundred
dollars so it's a third world country
right so I know the exchange rate stop
stop stop
what I'm being real can I just be real
with you yeah if I'm in the Philippines
let me and Chang Dante or on the
Philippines okay
we're hanging out on the beach and he's
like tanning next to you holding no
we're holding hands okay okay
I'm not holding here it's okay to hold
holding and I look over and I just go
hmm I just want to chop in half with a
machete and I just pull up a machete and
I just chop them in half on the beach
broad [ __ ] daylight but what would
have would I okay I mean now I'm
arrested okay
and I go hey I'll pay you guys a million
dollars can I get off there's a good
chance that somebody will at least allow
you back or allow you out of the country
to hide somewhere else
that's just how third-world countries
will I would in America who say if I
kill another American American in the
Philippines that would is that if I
could I get arrested in United States no
you would you're subject to the laws of
the land always to the judicial system
of the Philippines try to figure out how
to kill Chang without [ __ ] example for
example right my uncle in broad daylight
severed my other uncle spinal cord
slashed him - them in broad daylight and
he got 12 years which is pretty [ __ ]
good for a murderer
that's a [ __ ] wait so many witnesses
and he he admitted to the crime you know
and he didn't get life he was like you
know what we're gonna give you 12 years
you didn't kill him so you did kill him
here let me die 12 years a lot for a
vest lice paper cut yeah it's my uncle
Neal oh by the way that's my dad sorry
No all right Pete - my dead uncle though
I bet him - you didn't had the murderer
I bet the ghost of your [ __ ] uncle
no he I met his the murderer yeah he's
really nice but also at the same time I
was scared you should because I knew the
story so I just kind of kept my distance
you know like Korean families have that
chip in their head where it's like the
rage comes out out of nowhere
yeah I think that my uncle has the same
thing where it's like he's an Isis most
like the chillest dude ever but
something just switches when he's angry
and he just starts
it's really scary